thank you
new video first from our 8 news now
investigators moments after police say
NFL star Alvin Kamara and three other
men beat a man outside of a nightclub
prosecutors say Kamara essentially
admits to battery moments later in that
limousine his lawyers say it was all in
self-defense eight news now investigator
David charns following every new
development he's here now with more
video that you just obtained all new at
six o'clock David well this new video
shows Alvin Kamara and his group in this
Escalade leaving that nightclub just
minutes earlier police say Kamara and
three other men including another NFL
player beat a man in a hallway we do
want to warn you some of these videos
are graphic
it's 6 30 in the morning in February
2022 one day before the NFL Pro Bowl
prosecutors Say Alvin Kamara is sitting
here behind the driver just minutes
after beating a man in a hallway outside
a Las Vegas nightclub
a year later there is a lawsuit just
minutes before the group got into that
car a surveillance camera outside Dre's
after dark rolls Kamara a running back
with the New Orleans Saints now
Cincinnati Bengals cornerback Chris
lemons two other men and several women
crowd the area waiting for an elevator
Kamara is wearing the white tee Lemons
with the braids and the long sleeves the
victim appears to talk to the group when
the punches begin they move down this
hallway when prosecutors say the group
kicked and punched the victim he falls
to the ground the video showing several
people stomping on him minutes later the
group walks up a stairwell and leaves a
camera capturing Kamara and lemons
getting into their waiting car she said
the beating victim was left like this
injuries to his face eye and shoulder
lawsuit dude he's now suing Kamara for
10 million dollars in a civil lawsuit
so we asked the NFL for comment about
all this and the release of these videos
once again today a spokesperson saying
they don't comment on ongoing legal
matters he also says this is all under
review of the League's personal conduct
policy remember this happened now a year
ago as we mentioned kamara's attorney is
telling us this was self-defense and
they do intend to fight this charge at
trial all four men do in court here next
week I'm David charns eight news now
great work there David now you can watch
more of these video clips right now on
8newsnow.com and inside our free app the
grand jury indictment means the case
bypasses Justice Court a special
essentially speeding it up for a
possible plea deal or a trial the